I like to thank the organizers for
inviting me I just give you a brief
outline you know basically I would talk
a little about what we do at the Space
Telescope Science Institute give you
some background the Hubble Space
Telescope and things like that where we
were in 98 and the problems we were
facing and how we were able to use
Python to get out of the jam way we're
in and then you know give some
discussions about where we're going and
various observations about programming
in astronomy and scientific areas in
general so this is just a picture of
where we're the Space Telescope Science
Institute is responsible for the
scientific operation of the Hubble Space
Telescope and the next telescope that's
coming the James Webb Space Telescope
it's located on the Johns Hopkins campus
there are I think currently about 650
people working there and so a little bit
of background about the Hubble Space
Telescope to give you idea here's the
mirror that was used
you see people looking closely at the
mirror before was installed in the
telescope they unfortunately weren't
looking closely enough but it's it's not
large as telescope mirrors go there are
much larger ground-based mirrors but
there are advantages to being in space
that I'll briefly outline so it was
launched in 1990 it's been up for a
quarter of a century and working for
that like the time so that that that
time scale in space is pretty unusual
and so here's a picture of it in orbit
so a few words about why even though
it's not a large telescope why why
there's a big advantage to being in
orbit they're free big reasons one is if
you're on the ground the atmosphere
blurs the image so you can get much
sharper images
from space because the effects of the
blurring of the atmosphere essentially
been removed the second reason it's it's
less obvious to people is it if you're
on the ground the the atmosphere
scatters light and that provides a
background of everything you're looking
at if you're looking at really faint
things it gets really hard to see those
faint things against a glowing
background so in space there's a much
much weaker back on there still is a
background but it's far less in on the
ground and the third reason is there are
some wavelengths that just don't make it
through the atmosphere at all Ultra what
ultraviolet for example as much
attenuate as is the infrared so you know
for that reason you can do a lot of
things that would be very difficult from
the ground so I'm gonna be silly not to
show you some images from the Hubble but
what I like to start out is to sort of
contrast what these improvements look
like and so here's something that shows
the comparison of ground-based data on
the left is an image in a ground-based
Subaru the large telescope and on the
right the corresponding image from the
Hubble Space Telescope and you can see
so the image is on the bottom are
essentially just two blown-up parts that
what's shown in the rectangle there and
you can see the amount of detail and the
faint objects that you can see in the
space-based image are just there's no
comparison between the two but as I
alluded to not all went well right after
launch it turned out there was a problem
with the mirror it was made to the wrong
prescription basically and it was a
serious error so you know we have part
of the image cut off here at the bottom
so this is illustrate the bottom right
image is a ground-based image from
Palomar the image above it was the
original image from the Hubble Space
Telescope before the correction for the
mirror problem was introduced so you can
see there's a lot of detail there you
can see that you can't see from the
ground
on the other hand it's not nearly as
good as after it was corrected which is
the upper left and so you could you
could almost say that the improvement
the improvement from the first post
launch image over the ground-based image
is matched by the improvement after they
made the correction to the telescope and
a lot of people think oh well couldn't
you do some image processing to you know
remove the effects of the spherical
aberration the bottom left is an example
of trying to do that with the upper
right image and you can see there is
just no way to recover all the
information you see in earth an honest
you know the properly focused image like
you see the two arrows in the upper left
hand corner you there's no way you could
really identify those in the deke
involved image at all and just one more
comparison this is actually this is a
zoomed in part of the next image I'm
going to show which it gives you a more
global perspective of comparison these
the right is the post correction image
from the Hubble and the left is before
the correction was done so you can see
there's a big smearing effect you sealed
fine details but there's this big
smearing effect so after it was
corrected I pretty much the the original
design goals of the telescope were being
met so now I'm going to just go go
through quickly through and show you a
sort of a height so a bunch of
highlights of some images that I
selected some for having some unusual
aspects but the next one is just pretty
much a generic image of Saturn I think
everybody recognizes that here's one of
Jupiter that right after fragments of a
comet impacted the surface so you can
see those as the dark dark spots on the
the surface of Jupiter
here's one that shows in an Aurora on
Jupiter so an earth is not the only
planet that that sees a aurora let's see
the next ones of an alien oh wait I'm
not supposed to show this one
that's not for public release a star
farming region a nebula full of dust and
gas moving out in the universe with
these images this one is a really cool
thing what you're seeing here is that
that central star it's a sequence of
images and that central star is sort of
it went off like a flash bulb and that
flash of light has excited the gas
around it that normally would be
invisible but is excited it so that's
reradiating and so as a function of time
you're seeing different surfaces through
that nebula the structure of it as that
light expands and a shell around the
nebula so you're actually getting a sort
of three-dimensional rendition of this
nebula so this is called the light echo
this is a sort of the remnants of a
supernova that went off a few years
before the launch of Hubble and sort of
one of our satellite galaxies and you
can see the rings that are being formed
that central core so the Rings are
things that were already there but even
by that time in that very center you can
see the gas that was growing it you know
the star the shell of gas coming out of
the star was expanding in that time down
this is a a pair of colliding galaxies
and thinking that maybe a lot of people
don't realize as galaxies are largely
empty space and so for the most part
they pass through each other without
much effect as far as collisions go in
things hitting each other other than gas
but on the other hand they have
gravitational effects so they cause
these streamers of stars to be
pulldown so what you're seeing are the
sort of title effects of two two
galaxies and collision this is a core of
a very large elliptical galaxy that has
a high-powered jet coming out of it's a
very strong jet in the radio but you can
you can also see it in the optical in
this you can see the lots of what what's
happening here is is a very a relativist
beam of particles coming out that are
exciting the gas around it this one is a
image of what's called a gravitational
lens so this is an exotic thing that
we've seen a lot of lately it was only
first sort of discovered in 1979
something I have to do a thesis on
thesis on and what you're seeing here is
a cluster of galaxies but in the distant
background there are galaxies behind
them and there's enough mass in this
cluster of foreground galaxies it cut
distorts the light through gravitational
light bending and so you see these long
arcs are actually highly stretched out
distorted images of galaxies behind this
cluster and you see they're there
multiple these sort of very elongated
galaxies and and this gravitational lens
can is magnify the the light from these
background galaxies by a factor quite a
bit and the last image is a one of the
deep fields that Hubble has done
basically sitting on one spot in the sky
and taking very long exposures and the
important thing to here to realize is
that virtually every image you see in
here with the exception of maybe three
is a galaxy they're only three
individuals star two or three individual
stars on this particular image just to
give you an idea of how dense the
background of galaxies is so let me move
on to how we you know what our role in
and doing all this is
so our particular group works on these
basic things so our highest priority is
to calibrate the data coming from the
telescope and mostly it's to do this
automatically so all the data that comes
down in telescopes goes through these
calibration pipelines and you know
there's also in many cases now that
we're combining data from different
observations into one I'll show you
example that later we provide tools for
analyzing data we do some simulation
tools as well and we also have tools
that help with Serrat immers plan the
observations called exposure time
calculators they like to know if
telescope times very expensive and
they'd like to know well how long will I
need to observe something in order to
see if I suit make certain assumptions
about it so our software history was
originally our people had decided to do
their right these tools and Fortran and
then after some problems with that they
adopted a software package and system
called RF image reduction analysis
facilities actually stands for and it
was a system that was conceived and and
built in the late 70s early 80s it's
been an extremely successful system it's
still heavily used now so you're talking
about you know 35 years later it was
designed one of the big design goals of
it was to be portable and I'd say it's
been very successful at that but at a
price that I'll go into the next slide
so the idea is that the right
applications and if you know the
computers change the operating system
changed things like that you wouldn't
have to rewrite these applications you
would just rewrite this the they develop
what they called a virtual operating
system so this is a little like Java in
a way everything had to go through their
interface to the operating system and
that's how they
shielded all the changes of computers
from the system so that worked well for
a little while but the problem was there
were a number of issues that came up and
using RF one is in order to do this the
designer of the system decided that he
needed his own customer language so it
was something that Mike dissolute akahl
called spp which is the language is sort
of a hybrid between Fortran and C and is
a pre-processed into Fortran 66 Morgul
more or less and after a few years of
this there were a lot of programmers
that didn't really like the idea of
writing a program in language and nobody
else used the scripting language the
command line and the scripting language
is also a custom language with a lot of
its own quirks and weirdness and finally
a big issue was in in taking the
approach that they did they said you
know we will provide all the services to
your program well essentially you're
taking on a lot of responsibilities of
an operating system you have to provide
all these things and it turned out there
just wasn't they weren't enough
resources to keep up with the software
world so IRF basically is a sort of
snapshot of the way unix looked back in
the nineteen eighty and very little has
changed since then so we we tried to the
other problem was in in trying to make
changes and of all the system the
original group that worked on it was it
wasn't terribly receptive to having
other people help them do this so things
fell behind couldn't a lot of the
features you needed just weren't there
and it became a very frustrating
situation in the in their late you know
after 95 there was an attempt by us and
other institutions to try and have all
the system you know can we make it so
that you can link to libraries outside
of the irf core set of libraries you it
wouldn't let you link to any
arbitrary C or Fortran library because
of the way it was designed could we
write a language that everybody else
uses so there were some attempts he the
Institute wrote an interface to support
C programs written in C and it was
partially successful but never
completely successful and after a few
years of going down this road it
basically was it didn't work it never
really did evolve to the point that was
useful so we found ourselves in a bit of
a problem what are we gonna do about
this
we felt trapped we have a lot of
programs written in a language that you
can't just move to something else and so
you know what are the various uptight
kinds of solutions you could do well you
could say well we'll fork it we'll do
our own of evolution of the system
politically that's very difficult this
is system basically owned by a different
organization and now you you're
fragmented community it would lead to a
lot of lots of political problems we'd
slide that wasn't going to work well
right a new system or just do a massive
amount of rewriting that that also
wasn't politically feasible because in
essence you're going to have to say
there were millions of lines of code
written to the in applications at this
point for Ferrara and you're gonna say
well you know give us a few years just
wait until we rewrite everything in some
new system and we won't have anything
new for you for a while there was an
attempt to do this in Radio Astronomy
that sort of fell on its face and so as
a result of that and just the amount of
resources that would take you know just
you know there was no support for doing
it this way either so that you know
raises a question well what are you
gonna do I mean we felt increasingly
cornered in all this and then we saw a
movie that gave us an idea of how to get
out of the system even the the
suggestion and snake was very useful
the well what occurred to us is you know
the way to evolve out of this was to
provide allow users to be able to access
all the old tools and IRF that they
could have and start providing the new
ones that weren't written through its
interface but to give them sort of a
consistent user interface and by user
interface here I don't mean fancy gooeys
or anything like this it's just sick
this was basically a command line system
but they could run the new programs the
same way they ran the old ones and that
way you could say okay you know you've
got all the old tools we're gonna start
providing new ones that aren't you know
they use a different way and they're
mostly compatible and this would allow
us to gradually migrate away from the
dependencies on on the IRF virtual
operating system so this is this is how
our start in this was something called
PI Rev and PI ref was sort of an
interface we decided well we'll rewrite
the command line the command interface
the scripting language using Python it
would seem like the best choice at the
time and you know we surveyed all the
other alternatives and that didn't seem
to be any one that was good enough I was
in Python and and the thing that struck
us was you know our goals were pretty
limited at the beginning but we were so
impressed at the power of Python that
our goals became more and more ambitious
we ended up emulating the other
scripting language so that we could run
most of their scripts the command-line
syntax was exactly the same as before
we supported all the graphics and things
things that we initially weren't
planning to do we suddenly thought hell
you know there's a lot more we could do
with this so we ended up with a very
powerful alternative that said you can
run all the virtual II all the old
programs and you know write things and
something else that had you know you
call things and other languages
and you know so this would give us the
the the door we needed out of the this
Iraq system so after doing that you know
we he said wait not only was this a good
scripting environment we would really
like to be able to write our
applications in this language as well it
was a very nice language from our point
of view and so we thought it was quite
feasible to be able to use Python and
and we didn't do this sort of a was out
of the blue thought of doing this
because it turns out a lot of people in
an astronomy we're using IDL which is
another array base language similar to
MATLAB and that that that IDL was very
useful for a lot of applications and
optical Astronomy made it pretty clear
that if we could do the same things that
IDL did that we could it would be useful
and at the time though there were some
things that were missing numeric wasn't
good enough that was the array package
that it was around at the time it it had
some limitations for what we need to do
in astronomy
there were issue plotting I'll talk
about these a little more detail
plotting issues it was a real mess at
the time and we needed to be able to get
at the data and there's a special format
that astronomy uses for that called fits
so with a raise this is a little bit of
why there's a little bit of a tortured
history to the arrays and in Python so
numeric we we ended up starting around
2000 deciding to to try and rewrite
numeric that was called number a and
which was added a lot of very new nice
features but wasn't fast enough in small
arrays because it was implemented a lot
of us in fluent in Python which was
something grito had suggested and
and that's sort of what triggered Travis
to to rewrite it and see and numpy which
became possible at that time so a lot of
the capabilities what numpy has is sort
of a carryover of what number a had and
so it was it was a painful transition to
go through but I think in the end it was
we ended up with a much more powerful
much more powerful system than he had
originally and even better somebody else
now was taking care of it than than us
the that lot there were a lot of
plotting solutions available most of
them not terribly good they all had some
sort of important restriction they
couldn't work on all platforms that they
weren't free or they required as special
graphics windowing system to run or you
know things like that
and so we started out it's a our initial
effort was to work with n thought and
develop chaco but in the end it ended up
being I say a little too complicated for
astronomers to use they wanted something
that was a little simpler and so we went
looking and eventually ended up with
finding John Hunter matplotlib and
that's where yeah that's where we went
and after that matplotlib sort of became
the default scientific plotting package
and the last thing piped was it's a
standard data format that somebody had
already had a basic module to do that
but we wanted it to have a lot more
general capability in it it's it I'm
finally interesting that a lot of the
number-8 features that we felt we had to
have were driven by being able to
support this format well so structured
arrays
memory mapping being able to deal with
arbitrary memory order things like that
all essentially were driven by having to
support this format so I thought I would
show a couple examples of things that
we've used Python for and the first one
is something that we call Astra drizzle
and I give you a little bit of
background on this more and more with
the telescopes and the new telescope is
going to do this even more extensively
as the ideas when you're looking at the
sky you just don't take one exposure you
may take a number of overlapping
exposures for various reasons the
detectors some of the pixels are bad so
if you stayed looking in the same place
you may not see what's behind that bad
pixel but even more important than I
think the cosmic rays affect the images
a lot the next image will show you an
example that cosmic rays essentially
light up these pixels they're not really
real sources or just due to high-energy
particles hitting hitting the detector
so what you want to do is take all these
images that are taken at different
overlapping positions and combine them
in a way that makes a nice uniform image
you can't do simple shift in app because
of distortion so what's a right shift
where one pixel is the wrong [ __ ] for
another pixel and it needs really high
precision people can tell when there are
three thousandth of a pixel error in
misalignment we don't actually achieve
that I think the current accuracy is
about a hundredth of a pixel maybe two
hundredths of a pixel depending on the
situation but people can tell when it's
it's off by a few thousandths of a pixel
so that's a really stringent requirement
on that so here's an example the kind of
thing you'd be starting with is two two
images there are two two different
detector chips they have a gap so one of
the reasons you want to do these
overlaps is to fill in that gap between
the
the two chips but you see most of those
things that look like stars in that
upper image are cosmic rays they're not
real and so what you want to get out of
this is you know figure out based on oh
this only shows up in this image on this
part of the skies for one out of five
images so it's not a real pixel don't
don't include that so you you'd end up
with a mosaic like that where all the
cause virtually all the cosmic rays have
been eliminated and now you have a much
cleaner image different orientation in
this case so that's a fairly complicated
extensive procedure you have to go
through to to match these images get the
backgrounds like all this sort of thing
now the I thought I'd bring into the the
kind of things we were doing some
something about the new telescope we're
working on James Webb Space Telescope we
it's not in orbit yet and it's a lot
bigger
instead of being 2.4 meters like HST is
it's 6.5 meters it's made up of 18
hexagonal segments I'll show a picture
and execute it shows a model of it and
it's an infrared telescope and so
because of that the the mirrors have to
be kept very cold because if they're
warm they would glow in the infrared you
don't want a glowing telescope and when
you're taking pictures and it's gonna be
very far away it's not going to be
serviceable to me until the second
launch point which is about a million
miles away and so and here's a quick
image of the scale as hell scopes it's
an open structure and this is just there
are no real mirrors on this or anything
so and it has this multi-layered
sunshade that unfolds when it gets in or
all this sort of is wrapped up into a
much tighter package when it's launched
and it unfurls on its way way out to the
l2 point and here we've been involved in
the metrology of this so one of the
first projects we had to do
is they they wanted one of their car
Matz's well they can adjust the mirrors
so that they're all cophased they don't
do it actively that is it isn't done you
know in real time and so once adjusted
the mirrors have to stay very stable and
and you know if there's slight
temperature changes they can't drift out
of this and the kind of stability
they're talking about nanometers so they
want the these things to be stable to
tens of nanometers with the change of a
degree or two this is meant to operate
about 40 degrees above absolute zero and
so this was a test structure and they
wanted to actually they had to they were
required to see that it would in fact
stay that stable and when it was cooled
down and so an interferometer was used
to study this the interesting thing is
uh HST and jwc are not really big data
problems they generate pretty modest
amounts of data because for something
that's got to be launched it's generally
old technology and you're also limited
by communication bandwidth and things
like that so we're never dealing with
gigantic gigantic amounts of data button
the cases when you're doing taking data
of the telescope where was where we
actually faced a lot more data here we
had to take five images a second for
weeks and weeks and weeks continuously
and analyze that and so what they want
to do is track the motion of these
through an interferometer so this is
just sort of a quick illustration of a
succession of images that I want what
you're seeing are phased raft images and
so what you have to do is unwrap these
in phase and tie them together in time
and things like that but you see this
and that represents a such structure you
saw in the previous image and then you
know you tie all those together and you
can make a movie of that oops
maybe I can't play this the and show how
this structure is changing in time I
have to point out this has got the bad
bad bad color lookup table and people
shouldn't use maybe Mike or somebody
else will explain that yeah but this was
done a few years ago so and even now
we're actually we're doing
interferometry on the mirrors themselves
and we have interferometers that could
capture data 5,000 images a second so
you can really collect a lot of data and
very short short about a time so so
briefly Python allowed us to escape from
this sort of Iraq trap that I described
most of the new applications are writing
they are written in Python now that's
made us much more productive and it's
made us willing to tackle much more
difficult problems than we would have
before in the language and the system
that we were developing in the past so
the the focus we've gone through a few
things I'd like to mention one of the
problems that we faced a few years ago
and I would say it's not a problem
anymore
is that distributing the software so I
think mentioning anaconda and Conda I
think basically have solved the problem
for us because I was really a big issue
for us was finding a way distributing a
software because we have to give these
tools to the astronomical community and
many of these people don't have root
access and things like that so our focus
is shifted now I think we have lots of
the basic tools available and I'll talk
a little bit about what our current
focus is so our mission is really to
enable people in that analyze data from
j-dub t1 when it's launched and sort of
continue removing the dependency on
legacy data analysis tools of which many
are still being used so a lot of the
work up to now what we've been doing is
sort of providing a fundamental
libraries I'll talk a little bit
more about that but what had not as much
has been done in writing actual
applications that sort of heard the
equivalent what IRA has so another
aspect is we've been as it's fits format
I talked about is of has a lot of it was
advanced at its time again it was
developed around 1980 but it's
increasingly restricted and difficult to
deal with so we would like to find ways
around that and also foster an open
source community and this is something
astronomy has not been good at but I
think we've seen a lot of progress
lately and that's something I'll talk
about a little bit more so I've talked
mostly about what the Space Telescope
Science Institute it's done but what
about rest of astronomy I would say I
don't think it's an exaggeration to say
that when we we started Pi RAF we helped
trigger Python is sort of becoming the
standard language in astronomy it is
basically the language all the big
institutions now adopt and and as a
result of that a lot of the let me
now something that was I would say more
difficult to sell so a lot of these
institutions adopted Python mostly as a
scripting language I don't think it was
taken that seriously as a development
language itself it wasn't a real
language like C++ Java and that was also
partly because a lot of the libraries
another big competitor was IDL that had
an eye raft that had lots of astronomy
specific libraries so even though we had
sort of the basic tools applauding and
array manipulation we didn't have all
the astronomy lives of it available but
the attitude I think has changed quite a
bit here more and more places even the
big institutions now believe that it is
something that is a serious development
language and its own right and at this
point I'd say it matches IDL even at the
its better in its basic facilities and
IDL's and the richness astronomy tools I
think is probably fairly equivalent now
I'll mention it what you know why that
is I think it's also generally true that
most young astronomers coming in will
pick Python over anything else that's
where we've seen the big growth is and
you know it's a sort of standard thing
where it's awful hard to talk somebody
into switching from something they've
used for many years they have a lot of
time knowledge invested in it tools for
an init the people you want to convince
are the people coming into the field
that are adopting new tools and that
that's very much happened this is a
overlaps a little bit of what Travis was
talking about its interactive tippity is
a really important aspect of things
it's accessibility to scientists as a
fit your brain kind of thing you don't
have to become a big expert nobody iref
nobody would you right Park a very few
people write programs for an IRA because
they were it sort of these big black box
things and there are no libraries you
could get it easily in Python the
libraries are something you can
get it at different levels you can get
it top level you know lower levels
there's a whole spectrum of
accessibility and now it but it's a
powerful enough for programmers so you
have people sharing the same same tool
set you know you have expert programmers
astronomers and if it fosters
communication that's between the two and
when in the past they would be using
entirely different tool sets so and
there's one thing missing in all this
though and it is I think a lot of people
sort of look at this from a very
technical perspective you know this is
why is why is Python so good you know
disappear your technology yeah that it
is I mean it's but I would say it's not
the probably the it's not the only
reason and it's probably not the most
important reason again a lot of
technical people sort of look at and
they want to see all the features and
knobs and you know capabilities that
something has but that's not really what
I I would say that's not the the core
issue so this is something you came to
prepare to me when I went to the first
Python conference I went to which was a
98 which was I discovered an entirely
different culture
it was stark whereas in astronomy I saw
very little sharing lots of fragmented
efforts
lots of top-down planning committee
oriented stuff argument and analysis you
know it just wasn't a very productive
environment what I saw in Python
community was entirely different you
know sort of the opposite on all these
areas you know very very cooperative
even between businesses not not just an
academic level lots lots of cooperation
no top-down planning really people that
decided on how things were done with
people that were doing the work and a
lot of experimentation so you'd see two
or three different efforts you know
maybe the original one that everything
everybody thought would succeed was not
the one that that became the you know
the one that was so it was a real you
know this is something we could learn
from this I mean there there are reasons
for differences you know I'm not going
to go through all these all right I
would argue the last one was probably
the most important one people that are
invested in Python know they're
competitors and so they have a they have
a unifying mission to succeed and make
sure that they don't have to do
everything else again and that wasn't
true in astronomy you know most of these
people didn't succeed or die whether
they can you know cooperated with the
rest of the community there's a little
bit of a check chicken-and-egg aspect
going on here
I think that's changed in the past five
or six years and I would say there's
some you know there's change in the air
one of the reasons is five years ago you
know there was enough work going on in
Python and astronomy that they realized
there was a lot of redundant overlapping
efforts and it was time to sort of bring
this all together into one core package
called aster PI and the idea was you
know to set some standards and make some
consistency of interfaces to make every
you know try to make everyone use the
same tools you know reduce a lot of
redundancy provide documentation and
testing all these things and so a stripe
I actually consists of a course system
but then their affiliated packages that
no people could write to say I'm basing
this on Astro PI so this way you foster
a lot more cohesive community out of
this and it's actually been pretty
successful there are three coordinators
of which I'm one of them we've gotten
142 people that have made commits and 18
of those have made over 100 commits so
it's actually been growing over time and
then gaining a lot of adoption so I
would say it's yeah it's been quite
quite successful and now there's a
community that I think has something
invested in it and I think there's now
that the Astro PI is there there is a
reason for people to want to keep this
going and and add to the add to this set
of tools so Astro PI has basically been
successful in providing IO
fitting libraries dealing with
coordinate systems and time and lots of
basic things now and more the effort now
is I think focused on doing applications
levels and so the some of that will go
and asked by a lot of that will go into
the affiliated packages so a lot of
progress is continuing and so I'll just
finish on saying that a lot of people
worked on this you can see on the list
of somewhat truncated list of
contributors people worked on Astro PI
and a lot of people at the Institute
have contributed to a lot of things many
of which some of these things have gone
into a stop I itself so I miss if I
didn't mention the large effort that's
gone into this and and the reason to
stand a little bit on this is why Python
has been successful is that it has
fostered a community of people that want
to contribute to it and so that's really
the key to success and a lot of this is
making sure that not only do you have
good technical things but you're
receptive to building the tools so if
you look at Python thousands of people
have contributed to it it is not just
the effort of one man and even in the
scientific community you're talking
about thousands of people that have
contributed of course that so enabling a
community that it's willing to build on
things is really I'd say the key issue
it's not the tech
issues it's the sociological issue of
getting people to buy into and
contribute to doing this software on
that ll end and take any questions you
have
initially I think it was this idea that
you know it really wasn't a serious
language right you know
and so you would see a lot of effort so
the funded efforts although this is the
interesting thing is a lot of this work
there's only I would say there's only
been one institution that's actually
been behind that now it's ours almost
all the other work and Astro PI's
involve most of the effort to it has
come from outside that all that's been
sort of underground there there has been
no institutional support for Astro PI
except from the Space Telescope Science
Institute which I think has been very
useful but the lack of that is you know
sort of this getting a in order to get a
proposal and funding for it means you
have to do things that may make it
unsuccessful and that's true of a lot of
the big projects you know they have
their own issues you know a lot of
resistance to to using this so most of
what you see here is come come from you
know grass grass roots so I think that's
that's where it had to come from and you
know it's all very little of it at the
institutional level
someone back there
yeah he wants to know for using anaconda
at all Friday our solutions so this was
a problem for us we came up with our own
solution initially called Eureka which
was sort of built loosely on what sage
was doing but now given the success of
Conda and anaconda our next release of
Eureka will be based on anaconda and I'm
not sure exactly one that'll be out
within if within a few months so yeah
we're using we're gonna be using
anaconda and Conda future the biggest
issue was so we still distributed Iraq
because there people still use that and
so I refuse got this its own weird way
of building and distributing software
and so that's really the key issues can
you can you support that and I think
they found a way to be able to put that
into the condom framework
well let's see how can i word this the
the big delay was a budgetary one not so
much a technical one but one might see
it's not uncommon for space projects to
overrun their budgets by a lot and you
could almost hazard a guess that that's
part of the the way the game is played
in this case there's a little bit funny
in that when they ran into this
situation here it was treated
differently than things in the past so
the delay was a big one so the when the
contractor said we need more money they
were sort of faced with a question okay
well what would the impact on the
schedule be and I think the contractors
came back decided that they threw out a
number that nobody would accept we'll
have to delay it four or five years to
which NASA okay we'll do that so there
was one Barry B you know I think it went
from 2014 to 2018 and one jump because
they said well we have to limit how much
we're spending on a per year and so that
got stretched out quite a bit so and
it's always you know there's these
projects grow in size maybe everybody
was more and more careful because they
have so many eggs in one basket now that
nobody wants to screw up on this and so
there's a lot of testing and despite
what people say that it's all
off-the-shelf hardware it's it's never
all the off-the-shelf hardware there are
always a lot of technical issues yeah
do we see any other modern languages
useful for us you mean JavaScript for
you no web you know the browser probably
use C when we need to we tend to avoid
C++ if we can I mean there's always this
issue of how do you deal with object
systems you know do you and if you have
it in C++ and Python then you have these
issues of who owns memory and what you
know and so our focus has generally been
do as much in Python as you can and when
you have to you know drop in to see but
drop in to see at a low level
don't you see plus plus the manager oh
yeah actually believe it or not JW sees
scripting language on board is
JavaScript and for odd historical
reasons they did consider Python at one
point but believe it or not you know the
the on board scripting language is
JavaScript so all right
you